okay today I'm going to be talking to
you about gas pressure we're going to
find out what gas pressure is and three
different things which can affect gas
pressure so first of all I'm going to
show it draw you a diagram so this is a
closed container and within it there are
so I'm going to draw four gas particles
so remember in a gas the particles are
spread out and they move randomly in
every direction now obviously if this
was reality there'd be millions and
millions of these particles so as the
particles move they collide with the
walls of the container and as they
collide with the walls of the container
they exert a force now this overall
force is referred to as pressure so
every single collision of all of these
kind of act together and that overall
force exerted on this area here on the
kind of surface area of the container is
called pressure so the first one we need
to know about we're going to learn three
different things that affect pressure
the first one we're going to look at is
the number of particles so let's have a
look at two different situations here
I've got two different containers but
they have the exact same volume now in
the top container let's say I haven't
got many gas particles whereas in the
bottom one I've got many more so what
we're gonna have a quick think about is
which one of these is going to have a
higher pressure now if there's not many
particles there will be fewer collisions
with the outside with the with the walls
of the container if we've got more
particles there will be more frequent
collisions so the more collisions that
there are the higher the pressure will
be so this top one will have a low
pressure whereas this bottom one will
have a high pressure so if we have more
particles within the same volume will
have more collisions or more frequent
collisions therefore a higher pressure
the second one we need to know about is
volume
so again let's have a look at two
different examples so the top one we've
got a quite a large volume compared to
the bottom one so let's make sure we've
got the same number of particles in both
different situations keep it fair now
which one is going to have a higher
pressure this time so we're thinking
about the frequency of collisions
because there's a smaller volume here
there's going to be more collisions or
more frequent collisions than this one
here so therefore there's going to be
more force exerted on the walls of this
container so therefore this one has a
lower pressure and this one has a higher
pressure so as long as you keep the
number of particles the same as you
decrease the volume you will increase
the number of the frequency of
collisions therefore you will increase
the pressure the final one we need to
know about is temperature so we're going
to look at two different situations this
top one here and this bottom one here
now I'm what we're going to do is going
to keep a number of particles the same
so we'll just show four in each one
we've got the same volume each time what
we've changed this time is the
temperature so let's say this top one is
5 degrees C whereas this bottom one is
200 degrees C now when these these
particles are cold they don't have much
kinetic energy so kinetic energy just
means movement energy so let's think
about the force that they're exerting on
the walls of the container because
they're not moving with much kinetic
energy the force is going to be quite
low therefore the pressure will be low
as well
because remember pressure is just the
kind of net force upon the on the
surface area of the inside of this
container now imagine this we heat this
up to 200 degrees Celsius these
particles are going to have much
much much more kinetic energy now so
even though we're not even though we've
got the same volley with the same number
of particles the force that they're
colliding with the inside of this
container is much greater than this one
here also it will be more frequent as
well because they're moving faster so
these two factors result in having high
pressure so just to summarize gas
pressure is all about particles
colliding with the inside of container
if we have more particles in the same
volume will have a higher pressure as we
decrease the volume we increase the
pressure and as we increase the
temperature we're giving the particles
more kinetic energy and therefore we are
increasing the pressure as well thank
you